s'est procuré une photo de jeff quand il
était enfant au revoir non non non
encore amer vous ne vous étiez pas
encore rencontré regardez la photo de
jeff en font alors j'ai des photos tous
les chroniqueurs
alors vous allez essayer de les
reconnaître d'accord dit tout ce que
vous pensez de leur regard des premières
photos c'est qui ça c'est qui ça ça me
diop c'est avec nous ça va ma critique
élevé de vélib en pleine forme j'avais
deux ans lie déjà bien mangé j'ai
découvert non mais tu étais déjà belle
toile soit apte à passer toute la vie
est un canot et tout avec un mec en ce
moment un peu il te dirai qui tu es
ouvert aussi un jeu tandis qu'ali we
sing sing a dit c'est comme ma soeur
n'était pas ma soeur je t'aimerai
beaucoup beaucoup et c'est l'amitié
qu'on l'amitié pata pata portes ne lui
il faut pas un bon voilà et tu sais que
je serai toujours là pour toi le
deuxième cycle à ces crises à s'étendent
et sacrément savez mes frères qui
avaient des besoins des cheveux passé où
tous à son rival et fringues c'est
horrible
alléchant mais la chemise tfou revenir à
la mode mais si déjà la moitié il est
beau arrêtez-vous après que sa mère des
toits tafer bout papa ou jours talend
sont fait toujours mal est fait toujours
mal quand tu étais petit était mignon
d'embarquer dit la vérité
merci jean mas c'est qui ça vous ne
voyez pas c'était en trombe avant
jugement sur ma vie elle
on la reconnaît directeur d'ajouter m et
shawn est la même elle a cure et le
stylisme et bon bah ouais et mais tu es
une retraite par ma mère ma mère me
faisait toute armée elle même parce qu
elle claudie syrie mais les mignonnes
celle ci il a toujours été belt ou la
vie de la mort j mais là c'est vrai que
j'ai tant mieux et alors ce qui est
quand même assez rare je pense que je
suis la seule ça qu'on est là voyez où
il ya les photos
oui photo où il ya les cadeaux pardon
oui eh ben à mon âge aujourd'hui c'est
le même quoi où on met des les cadeaux
de noël avec ma mère ce n'est pas à
déménager ou pl et ans plus tard
j'espère santana ses empreintes dont
vous avez la merde mais c'est comme ça
tu peux pas voir ce qu'elle peut faire
et envie de chialer moi mais c'est bon
ça merci c'est sa 3ème cantat vient pas
plusieurs jours à linthal as 2000 la
troisième faute aussi des fermetures
tu étais à l'époque c'est un vrai
rebelle en fait ouais c'est vrai mais
j'aimerais de temps en temps et mais
c'est ouf
vers 7 8 ans et sa 7 8 ans je le sentais
mal dans l'ariège un peu rock'n'roll de
la vie ah ouais ouais ça se voit pas
tout le temps mais en tout cas cette
photo le représente bien il est il est
encore huit chalets fraude n'a été mieux
maintenant que tu as rangé ton tard on
n'a pas la même coupe de cheveux aussi
un vrai mandat mer mais reconnais pas
con mais c'est vrai regardez prochain ça
c'est peut-être déjà dieu bénisse la
venue de vieira couscous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dieu bénisse sur maville kelly tulameen
au restaurant faire il faut que tu
évoques d'apple aux banques et à m'en
ait ouvre une ligne de crédit du pdis un
non mais non c'est très joli
non mais attendez une telle somme et
c'est c
vous avez un commentaire à nous pas 10
ou ça va ouais vous êtes mignonne non
franchement moi vous trouvez
mais vous aviez cas là je n'avais pas
beaucoup de chemin non vous aviez
calabre c'est pas le problème dans les
très mignonne un an et l'accès savez pas
quel âge de vie de ces biens avait 14
ans bon allez minette franchement
j'aurais assez frais on s'effraie
sagement ses frais voilà le prochain ce
qui fait de moi le prochain fait bondir
moitié elle qui s'était bernard sancé
mlc qui s'allège
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bref cette opération pour devenir une
femme à quel âge je vais très court
quand j'étais petit dans mes pénates si
tu m'as un moment je me suis méfié qui
s'étire sans quoi ils ont sommé à photo
et franchement on vous voit la ville de
beni chars elles aussi à 1
alagui verts n'ont pas tellement pas que
je sais pas quand j'étais petit
comme messieurs - vous êtes revient
toujours vous avez toujours été très
joli nom voit pas bien mais je le savais
regardons s'appelait il ya est connu
c'est un mais accrochez vous avez vous
aussi vous êtes mieux maintenant ouais
oui notre photo
[Rires]
les mecs mais tu le mois la fin tu la
laisses enfants qui nous regardent
n'ayez pas peur
la méprise monde n'ayez pas peur c'est
cette personne mais mes frères c'est pas
possible tu te dis mais comment ils pas
mais les magies les gens te disais quoi
les les gens me repoussait c'est pour ça
que vous les jours on m'a jeté la tête
contre les murs et moi c'est sûr que ce
soit la bonne solution
non mais c'est ouf sans regret mais
franchement sceptique mois on a on a
quand même envie de te apprivoiser ses
cuisses à bonbons des isles n'ont pas de
dire monter à la seule fois toi c'est
pas du jeu qui frise et des minières
steco sait qui c'est toi
oui en train de regarder un koala qui
commencera pas eu à coire à noël je
crois qu'elle a vu un vrai qu à l'arbre
un koala et tu regardes comme ça comme
trop modéré
à l'époque il venait avant dévoile en
peluche oui ah ouais bah tu te vois pas
bien mais motion incidentielle montiel
c'est pas keystone dix ans
et toi ça y est c'est vrai c'est ma
tante attentes
la tempête alors et déjà tu avais déjà
une voiture d'où vous aurez à cette
année on voit que c'est une famille de
malades et il avait une voiture qu'on
n'a même pas de maintenant la salle 17
voitures la norme pour la voir dans
soyez mais même moi j'ai pas on l'a pas
cette voiture maintenant si ça devait
coûter très cher sarko me sent bon mais
crevard sur les guirlandes par contre
j'avais là il est pas bon sur les gardes
de m et un bébé qu'est ce qui se passe
est un très beau bébé est un très beau
bébé c'est un très beau bébé ben oui
c'est un beau bébé oui c'est un métier
très mauvais match petit symbolique à la
salle oui oui c'est un beau bébé
versez le prochain mois sa raquette
c'était pour noël ouais ouais mais
j'avais j'avais javel ou un arbre merci
à vous avez pris une photo de l'appui
c'est bon ça vole pas
[Rires]